a Google software engineer this week
circulated a memo criticizing company
policy with regard to tolerance and
diversity for which diverse opinion
Google tolerantly fired him will analyze
+ will analyze pardon the church of
political correctness n to Tara tix
blood samanda press to Giacomo Paul Bois
and Jacob berry joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss bureaucrats
climate change qu the MSN's declaration
of trumps demise and coddled Guide Dogs
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Magnolia
[Music]
right so you may be noticing if you're
watching this on video I have glasses
now I made it 27 years without glasses
unfortunately the old eyes died no I'm
not happy about it
but you know actually I think this could
be a good thing for two reasons one
we're going to be talking about those
nerds at Google today so if I'm going to
be a four-eyes this is as good a time as
any also this will help me complete my
full transformation into Rachel Maddow
so I've got the show now I've got the
hair and the physical stature now I also
have the glasses I'm very happy to say
that okay we have got to get to this the
other thing about these glasses I only
need them for distance I have to keep
taking them on and off to quote a great
man said we need just talked about this
this engineer his name is James demo
array or dumb or I'll pronounce it the
Italian way because I want to believe
that it was an Italian American who
published this beautiful memo that is
upsetting everybody at Google the memo
is titled Google's ideological echo
chamber and it went viral it was
criticizing the culture that they have
instilled at Google of political
correctness and diversity and tolerance
and this that and the other thing he's
of course been fired for bringing up a
diverse idea so he's lost this job after
this memo went viral both in the company
and on the Internet outside of the
company now before we unfairly lambaste
Google I think it would only be fair to
go to Google CEO sundar Pichai for
comment do we have them welcome to
tolerance camp you are here because you
would not accept people's differences
because you refuse to accept the life
choices of your fellow man well those
days are now over here you will work
every hour of every day until you submit
to being tolerant of everybody here
intolerance will not be tolerated Wow
very profound words not the accent that
I expected from a name like sundar
Pichai but he went on and explained a
little bit more he said after they can
to this poor guy he said quote much of
what was in that memo is fair to debate
regardless of whether a vast majority of
Googlers disagree with it however
however is that key word here because
however is negate sentences it negates
what came before it
portions of the memo violate our code of
conduct and crossed the line by
advancing harmful gender stereotypes in
our workplace much of it is up for
debate but if you violate the if you
commit a thought crime at Google you can
be fired because it violates the code of
conduct what a code of conduct that must
be he went on to say quote the memo has
clearly impacted our coworkers
some of whom are feeling or hurting and
feel judged based on their gender now
this is great
NPR is reporting this morning that there
are a number of women who work at Google
who to contradict this patriarchal and
sexist memo that was going around have
stayed home from work because they're so
upset about what was in the memo so way
to fight the patriarchy ladies the memo
said that you were overly emotional and
you really showed them didn't you
speaking of women at Google the VP of
diversity & Inclusion weighed in on that
as well Google's vice president for
diversity and inclusion sent a letter to
employees on Saturday saying the
employees memo quote advanced incorrect
assumptions about gender and is not a
viewpoint the company endorses promotes
or encourages there's one word missing
it endorsed politically incorrect
assumptions about all of those things
also what a job title the vice president
of diversity and inclusion I don't know
what graduate degrees or credentials you
need for that probably just a bachelor's
from a liberal arts university
Swarthmore maybe Wesley and I'm not sure
but great good for her that you got that
gig I can't imagine what they're doing
that is what this is about this is about
PC it's about political correctness and
that issue pervades the entire memo so
what is in this memo I think it's being
reported in certain areas of the
internet that the guy who wrote this
James de Moura is a conservative he is
not a conservative I read the memo this
morning he in many places criticizes
conservatives for various points of view
that the the right tends to hold in the
country but what he's really criticizing
is an oppressive environment that
stifles free speech stifles free
expression of ideas and also literally
discriminates against certain employees
and hiring practices and benefits that
are available
to employees so here's just a few few
quotes from the memo you should go over
read the whole thing it's eye-opening
that this would get a guy fired quote I
value diversity and inclusion I'm not
denying that sexism exists and I don't
endorse using stereotypes the
stereotypes is the key here it was more
on that later psychological safety is
built on mutual respect and acceptance
but unfortunately our culture of shaming
and misrepresentation is disrespectful
and unaccepting of anyone outside its
echo chamber the title of the piece is
about the echo chamber and of course
even a memo that was circulated at first
anonymously was enough to get a guy
discovered routed out and fired from
Google quote the lack of discussion
fosters the most extreme and
authoritarian elements of this ideology
and that's what he's talking about this
utter emphasis on diversity of skin
color on diversity of gender on
diversity of all sorts except for
diversity of thought the one diversity
that a company probably could benefit
from and and the authoritarian elements
of this as well you see here this vice
president of diversity inclusion all of
these managers whose entire job it is to
program their employees to host seminars
to host training practices to host all
of these events to change the way in
which these employees think and you see
this everywhere this is happening on
college campuses the diversity deans are
multiplying by the hour
Yale has probably hired three more since
we started this show today it's in
workplaces and it's across Google's
platforms there is a well-documented war
on conservatives at YouTube you know
they flew a lot of us out there about a
month ago I was us I went out there
Steven Crowder went out there not gay
Jerrod our panelists or sometimes
analysts a lot of people from across the
spectrum went out google said listen
we're going to try harder they've
already cut off a lot of the revenue to
conservative channels a lot of
conservatives have been banned from
YouTube altogether so hopefully there
will be some remedy in the future but
Google has made its ideological
positions quite clear now the big claim
beyond criticizing what Google is doing
the big claim that probably got this guy
five
is he he committed the thought crime he
committed the one unthinkable thought
crime he said men and women
categorically are not exactly the same
did you hear that Marshall Marshall ran
out of the room running out of the room
crying can you imagine that claim he
said that there are heritable
differences between men and women
they've been observed across all of
cultures for all of time these
differences can be explained solely by
social environments or social
conditioning but they are biological as
well and he made a few generalizations
here which all the women at Google
proceeded to prove correct one after
another this morning but he made a few
claims he said women speaking
categorically not speaking individually
not saying there aren't women who don't
have these characteristic Touran men who
do have these characteristics but he's
speaking categorically he says that
women are more show more openness
directed toward feelings they tend to
invest more in personal relationships
rather than in relationships to things
that women express extraversion
more through gregariousness or more
agreeable certainly this is true there
are other social science studies to back
this up that women are more prone to
anxiety this is obviously true it's been
backed up by myriad psychological
studies it's been backed up by
pharmaceutical sales but that that in
particular riled the feathers of many in
the upper echelons of Google and that
research suggests that greater nation
level gender equality leads to
psychological dissimilarity in men's and
women's personality traits so as there
is a national ideological push for
equality and indiscernible 'ti of the
sexes that those inherent biological and
categorical differences between men and
women become a little clearer they
express themselves a little bit more it
crucially he says many of these
differences are small there is
significant overlap between men and
women so you can't say anything about an
individual given these population level
distributions this is the key because
when when Google or rather when people
on the Left who present this ideological
point of view presented it seems that
there are these binary categories that
we're
but we're not we're saying that there
are bell curves there are there's
significant if not major overlap between
those two categories and most
importantly while the left wants to put
us all into little boxes and engage in
the intersectionality pyramid of an
hierarchy of oppression the right
generally speaking wants to judge people
individually you stereotypes come from
somewhere perhaps but you can't judge an
individual based on categorical
assumptions and definitions a firm
belief of the conservative movement
among individualist libertarians people
on the right this is what got Larry
Summers fired this isn't the first time
it's rearing its ugly head Larry Summers
is president of Harvard he presented a
study that suggested that there were
several reasons why women do not appear
at the high end faculty of stem of
science technology math engineering and
one of the possible reasons is that
categorically speaking the bell curve
might be different so the bell curve for
women might be a little smaller than the
bell curve for men meaning the ten
dumbest people on earth and the ten
smartest people on earth would be men
and then otherwise there would be
perfect overlap between men and women
this was enough to get M can from that
position Larry Summers no conservative
Republican lifelong Democrat the there
was there's also a woman hadn't won the
Fields Medal then that mathematical
prize until 2014 there were there is
obviously a lack of women at these in
these particular areas and there's also
a lack of women at Google itself
something like 75% of the leadership of
Google is male 69% of the staff is male
so certainly this is a male-dominated
field and for this guy James tamori to
ask why to say it's perhaps not just
oppression and you know keeping women
down because of a glass ceiling in the
patriarchy perhaps there are some other
reasons is enough to lose him his job
now he goes on to talk about
discriminatory practices apparently at
Google there are programs mentoring
classes only for people of a certain
gender or race special treatment for
diversity candidates which might
effectively
lower the bar for certain people who are
being hired there appear to be some
illegal quotas from what he wrote in his
memo and this shows I think a
discrepancy between the left's
understanding of conservatives and
conservatives understanding of the left
there the guy who put it better I think
is Jonathan Hite who's a social
scientist he put it in a TED talk
probably the only TED talk I've ever had
through the difference between how we
view each other on both sides of the
aisle do we have so if you think if you
think that half of America votes
Republican because they are blinded in
this way then my message to you is that
you're trapped in a moral matrix in a
particular moral matrix and by the
matrix I mean literally the matrix like
the movie The Matrix but I'm here today
to give you a choice you can either take
the blue pill and stick to your
comforting delusions or you can take the
red pill learn some moral psychology and
step outside the moral matrix we can say
that liberals have a kind of a two
channel or two foundation morality
conservatives have more of a v
foundation or five channel morality we
find this in every country we look at
here's the data for 1,100 Canadians I'll
just flip through a few other slides the
UK Australia New Zealand Western Europe
Eastern Europe Latin America the Middle
East the East Asia and South Asia now
what are you saying is that concert'
there are more moral categories by which
conservatives view the world in which
they see the world different different
ways to value our place in the world and
others around us and the things around
us for the left it's narrower it's more
myopic and so when someone on the right
or a conservative sees someone on the
left doing something stupid they might
say well that's pretty stupid you
clearly don't see the world in its full
picture or in a full enough picture but
c'est la vie
that's that's how these things go
whereas when someone on the Left is a
conservative doing something because
they don't understand these other moral
categories they don't have this broad a
moral vision of the world they assume
malice they assume ill intent or some
nefarious plotting on the part of the
conservatives now this kind of language
is really disconcerting we see it
throughout the culture listen
to the doublespeak that we hear from
other Googlers other managers of Google
I think a culture of silence in games
Vidya and I think a culture of
vulnerability can be beautiful a mantra
that that we really tried to embrace
here at Google is bring your whole self
to work yeah a culture of silence can be
insidious and let's talk about the
culture of vulnerability the people who
are most likely to lose their jobs if
they open their mouths it is he is
stating precisely the opposite of what
he means to state which is that if you
hold certain views you will be routed
out in the in the name of tolerance and
diversity and fairness despite the very
act of doing that undermining all of
those things entirely let's go on we
have various groups that are called
urgent employee resource groups that
focus on a variety of things from
serving the black Googler community to
Hispanic Googler community too we have
another group called gayglers
and we're not often aware of how our
bodies are actually already living
inside of us inclusion continues to be
something that we really need to
innovate around and work on I'm going to
start calling Marshall a gayglers that's
in a totally separate point and it's
been great that's the great little word
of course ever since
Google realized they had this problem
where men are dominating the company
they addressed it by creating safe
spaces that's language that they'll use
to describe it and those spaces are
called employee resource groups as part
of the program diversity core and you
can go and you can share your feelings
certain employees are allowed to spend
1/5 of their time coming up with
initiatives to attract women and racial
minorities to the company since of their
time it's a lot of money it's a lot of
resources but of course that won't
attract diversity of thought so demora
has decided to file a complaint with the
NLRB National Labor Relations Board
we'll see what comes of that but I
imagine we can't take down the behemoth
either the tech company Google or the
culture that they are taking part of
with
that we have to bring in our panel
finally we have to bring in our panel
this is an all-day Lee Weyer panel today
we have the beautiful and brainy Amanda
presto Giacomo we have the less
beautiful and less brainy Jakob Barry
and Paul Bois His Eminence himself guys
thanks for coming here Paul you are a
member of the Congregation for the
Doctrine of the Faith how did the Church
of P see the cult of diversity and
tolerance arise well for that we have to
go all the way back to the time of Karl
Marx who is of course the first social
engineer to identify people according to
their economic grievances and this of
course translated into the social
spheres in the early 20th century with
philosophers like Michel Foucault and
Charles Fourier but that's a more
esoteric diagnosis and I don't think the
people at Google are necessarily
marching under that banner where I think
that virtue signaling gained such a mass
appeal stems from the fact that America
in the 60s and 70s lost its Christian
identity and it will I know you were
going to say that I am new working I am
yes you called me Vox Dei for a reason
so they lost its Christian identity and
lost its ability to forgive itself of
past sins and with that translated into
a mass attitude of intense censorship
and hatred of any idea that opposed the
specific coddling and targeting of
various minority groups so I think that
speaks to its mass appeal beyond that of
the hard left who I think are more
ideologically motivated sure and there
is a notion that when you lose the sense
of your connection to I am that I am
when you lose the connection of the
creature to the creator you have this
question which is who am i which
victimhood category do I fit into and
how do i exploit it for professional
gain at Google a very good question
Jacob is Google more than a private
company is you know there are these kind
of wonder it's a private company why
shouldn't they be able to do whatever
they want to do but are they more than
that they collude with the government
they have all of our data for every
single thing that we will certainly deny
having looked up on the Internet are
they more or they are they super super
of business you know are they import
government as well I don't think they're
in part government I but I do see the
argument that says hey they're doing all
these collusions like Google literally
has a system set up where they they read
everything you search in the Google
search bar and if something suspicious
comes up they report you to the
government and I think that why I'm I'm
hesitant to start an investigation into
Google they are a private company and
quite frankly they have the right to to
work with the government I think that us
as consumers need to put pressure on
them and say hey we don't like this we
want to see more conservative voices at
Google and on YouTube is there a fear
though I mean I agree with that
absolutely is there a fear Amanda that
this will trickle down to other
companies Google is obviously they're
lunatics they're out there in Silicon
Valley they partake of that the kool-aid
out there with all of the other tech
liberals is there a fear that this will
permeate other companies in the United
States I mean I think it already has I
mean we see it with Facebook we see it
on YouTube and this is all over the
place where conservatives are being
routed out you know you have some wrong
think and you're in your boot at you're
can't go to talking about diversity
policies and it wasn't apparently that
it's all under their diversity
guidelines and he was outed so I mean
we're already seeing it I guess the
answer would be to try to get
conservatives in this tech world you
know I don't know exactly how we do that
if if Google is to coordinate more than
government maybe you can have some sort
of case where you know there could be
some overreach but again I'm not one to
push any sort of government action to
you know restrain something thank you I
think you could have ended that sentence
after government action I am NOT one no
just stay out of here yeah and and stay
out of the rest of this conversation you
people who are too cheap to go to daily
wire.com speaking of Facebook in YouTube
we have to say goodbye to you both we
probably will have to say goodbye to you
both because we'll be kicked off there
shortly go over to Daley wire calm right
now you get the
the rest of the panel of deplorable
you'll get the leftist tears mug keep
your left is tears hot or cold always
salty and delicious and you can hear
Amanda and Paul and Jacob keep
pontificating on the news of the day but
only if you go to daily wire calm right
now ten bucks a month you get bench
bureau show Andrew flavin show and my
show so do it right now we'll be right
back
now we have to get to the important news
like the Sun monster federal agencies
have leaked a report on the dangers of
global warming while President Trump is
away on vacation it warns that
temperatures could increase two degrees
Celsius over the next hundred years and
if we stop if we don't do anything and
if we stop emitting these greenhouse
gases then they'll still increase half
of degrees Celsius over 100 years now
luckily we have a feed to the federal
climate officials environmentalist
bureaucrats what is your reaction
[Applause]
measures typical typically thoughtful
response from the federal bureaucrats
Paul aside from the global warming we've
talked about global warming let's talk
about the leak is this another example
of the deep state trying to undermine
President Trump an example of the deep
state no an example of fake news from
New York Times yes because according to
an article on Fox News right now there
actually was no technology several
scientists who authored the report are
now publicly claiming on Twitter that
the New York Times published fake news
and that the report was available on the
internet archive's going all the way
back to January so no deep state here
but Trump's other enemy fake news
absolutely fake news New York Times that
is a much more dangerous enemy than
those bureaucrats Amanda President Trump
is likely going to ignore this report I
assume his USDA has stopped using the
term climate change apparently they're
now instructed to use the term extreme
weather can we say safely that we're
living in the best timeline is this just
the best thing ever
it really I'm just waiting for President
Trump to retweet his old tweet about
China creating colleges who basically
hurt you at a factory like what's that
been that it's the best time ever but
good on Trump this is why this woman
brings buckyball conservatives and
people on the right voted for Trump
because he's not going to put up with
the propaganda with the PC language you
know the global cooling global warming
then climate change
and kind of changes the PC propaganda
term in and of itself good for him to
read it we're playing by his rules this
is in part why he why he won that's
right this is boldness we have not seen
before it with many of the other men on
that stage who are running for president
2016 I don't think that we would see
turning away from the language of
climate change or climate crisis or
whatever
Al Gore thinks up this morning is there
some evidence that President Trump is a
conservative in maybe a different way
and maybe a more meaningful way than
some of the other people that were
running for that seat well I should kind
of think it shows the opposite he thinks
like a leftist he goes after them uses
their tactics President Obama stripped
words away that you didn't want like it
you know what is myth is intelligence
reports or whatever some of in Trump has
that same you know focus that you can
play just as dirty as they are and so
it's kind of it kind of shows up them I
think takes a thief to catch a thief
very very true Jacob
regardless of the fake news from the New
York Times but I repeat myself are leaks
in general are they good for the
Republic we've seen so many leaks coming
out of the Trump administration are they
good for the Republic or do they do more
harm than good are they damaging to the
presidency in to the country
I honestly think they do more harm than
good
you see what everyone talks to old what
about Watergate Watergate with Banting
leaks and well if there's one problem
Watergate actually showed that there was
illegal activity going on
none of the leaks that I've been really
show any kind of illegalities none
whatsoever so I honestly think the ones
that are being released is just an
attempt to disrupt president Trump from
governing speaking of Watergate the
Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness as they tell me why shouldn't
poster in a headline this morning quote
Trump's base is officially crumbling
this is based on new polling data that
shows his approval ratings are falling
Jacob when did the Washington Post lose
all of its credibility was it
immediately after Watergate that they
have some leeway in between there why
how is it fallen so far when did it
happen I honestly think it happened in
the 90s we definitely saw the mainstream
media come to
gather for the first time openly you
know before it was kind of done in
subtle ways but definitely in the 90s
with with President Bill Clinton it was
done more in the open oh we're going to
cover up all the massive spending and
then all of a sudden in 2003 their their
fiscal conservatives under george w bush
for all the for all the spending bills
he wrote so you know i think that
honestly it came more out in the open in
the in the early 90s I would say
certainly with that motto that pathetic
motto they started this year democracy
dies in darkness you get headlines like
them surprised I didn't use three or
four exclamation marks at the end
ridiculous
Amanda the approval numbers are down
according to the polling Trump's numbers
are down especially among his base but
these are the same people who told us
that Hillary at a 99.999 percent chance
of being elected president should we
believe them are the numbers worth
believing or is it just more fake news
so I mean you got to be careful again
just coming from this election I'm not
one to just you know take these polls
and believe them wholesale you know
again this is the same media that's the
same analysts who are telling us that
we're going to see a referendum on Trump
with a special election set in turnout
but it but if we look at Rasmussen for
instance which is tend to be the most
accurate of these polls Trump that 41mm
the most right wing to the diplomatic
putting it love Rasmussen polling yeah
great bully
it's almost anonymous you know correct
right wing that's right so so basically
that that showed him at like forty one
percent so it looks like his numbers
kind of dropped off a little bit and
that could be you know if these are
legit at all that could have been you
know we saw Trump attack sessions I
don't think it's based particularly like
that you know just recently the mooch
wasn't the best time president I will
not hear that I don't believe that we
disagree I just a vellum and I just know
I love you much less beautifully if this
pulling is right at all we should see an
uptick pretty soon I mean president
Trump has a lot of good wins in the
foreign policy front so we'll probably
see we'll probably see these numbers go
up and again with general Kelley - we a
lot of calm down so I respect these No
if they're accurate at all to get a
boost anyhow if they're accurate at all
is a big qualifier well if the numbers
are legit
what can president Trump do to hold the
Congress in the midterms to be
re-elected what can he do to bounce back
well I absolutely think we can balance
back Michael I think Trump's rhetoric
Trump's agenda Trump's spirit I don't
think I read readily appeals to his base
I think most of them are just
experiencing fatigue over the past
couple months is attacking of Jeff
Sessions the scare Moochie ordeal I
think if he just gets over those and he
gets a well oiled machine going and he
brings them the magma that he promised
them I he'll bounce back and I think
he'll win in a landslide he just really
needs to get that going and it's really
a question of 10p oil his machine bring
me the magma bring me the calf essay
that that's all I want that's all I'm
asking for we have to get on go ahead
hand it I want it good say if you can
get the raise act to pass because you
know Republicans are terrible and some
of them already against if you can get
that to pass I think that'll base will
be really excited about that you'll have
to hurt all those cats in the Republican
Conference in Congress which is not the
easiest thing to do but if he can you're
right maybe he can bounce back you can
get a legislative win under his belt but
all of that none of that matters none of
that matters coming out of Congress or
the economy or the White House because a
new study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences
suggests that coddled puppies make poor
Guide Dogs is it important they make
poor Guide Dogs Amanda does this explain
our terrible generation it does it's
almost like parenting matters it's so
fine to see all these leftist headlines
like so shocked does it smell like have
an effect yeah I mean you cattle
children or puppies they're they're not
going to be the most capable or
self-sufficient or you know the best guy
dogs or the best people to hold a job
and not be in their basement basement
like they do it's all kind of connected
here so you know hopefully this will
click on the laptop is the fda's and
gender studies they get MFA's and are
yeah there's a lot of terrible effects
from
those parents coddling those poor
puppies Paul it has become cliche to
call Millennials snowflakes they have
been helicopter parented there is their
participation trophies there is grade
inflation sure but they're also stuck
with a ton of student debt unprecedented
student debt they are stuck with a lot
of federal debt the national debt
because of unfunded liabilities that
their parents have left them and not
paid for is it are we being too harsh on
the Millennials is it is it fair to call
them coddled well you brought me on here
so I'm going to say this I think it's
fair to call Millennials spiritually
malnourished and I think that largely
stems from the breakdown of family the
breakdown of important social structures
of the breakdown of religion and
morality and so I mean the way I put it
is the baby boomers had the party the
Gen Xers got the leftovers and the
Millennials got stuck cleaning it up you
know we're the generation you know
brainwash and a massive college debt
with a generation of broken homes with a
generation of technological gluttony so
I think they deserve a little bit more
of our pity than our scorn
sure absolutely is there is there a way
out though is there a way to satiate
their spiritual malnourishment or is
there any hope of a Great Awakening on
the horizon or are we all just headed
for a nihilistic nothing short of a
spiritual revolution is going to do it
but I mean if there's one thing that
does we should all definitely take
hoping is the fact that we're
Millennials are conservative and we're
they are religious they are very
conservative and they are very religious
there is a a very much a hunger among
millennial conservatives to seek the
Orthodox to seek sort of what was
deprived of them by the baby boomer
generation I think that's something that
may translate into a powerful social
revolution there's also clearly an
exuberance among young people but I'm
speaking politically here you know of
these kind of mischievous fun people are
both at the millennial generation a
little bit younger they don't seem to be
totally brainwashed politically correct
people they seem to be rebelling against
that a little bit so maybe there's some
hope who knows I'm an eternal optimist
Jacob back to the issue at hand
if we are spending money studying puppy
parenting shouldn't we have already
cured cancer or something or what you
know we've heard all of these stories
about federal science funding going to
run shrimp on treadmills and study
lesbian obesity or our resources being a
little misguided here
oh yes 101 percent how they allocate
these these studies I have no idea I
remember a Glenn Beck did this
performance where he was saying
unelectable and he said that anyone who
suggested that we would study what
happens when fire hits ice they should
just be taken out and executed now I'm
not advocating violence again against
these people but you know sometimes like
I definitely get the sentiment you know
it's like you know let's be against
sentence I think of terrorism what we
got we've got terrorism we've got actual
problems that funding for these studies
can go to and instead we're worrying
about lesbian dance therapy I know
that's a favorite attack of bin
Shapiro's who Alisa tackle is being
dance big theory and I'm all for it we
should we should cut it we should cut
the fat and focus on what's important I
keep inviting him to my lesbian dance
therapy class I think it would be really
good for him it would help him relax
he's a busy guy
he still hasn't taken me up on it okay
well on that cult of violence I have to
say goodbye to all of you because now it
is time for the final thought
[Music]
Google I'm going to put my smart glasses
on for this final thought Google keeps
using those words diversity inclusion
and tolerance I do not think they mean
what Google thinks they mean the company
has sent a crystal clear message today
that they will not tolerate any hint of
the only diversity that matters
diversity of thought in the name of free
thought they suppress speech in the name
of diversity they exclude those with
diverse points of view in the name of
tolerance the high clerics of Google
will not tolerate era tix GK Chesterton
and orthodoxy identified Google's
illiberal central premise the thought
that stops thought there is a thought
that stops thought he wrote that is the
only thought that ought to be stopped
wise words
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow and we'll
do it all again
[Music]